ne quittons pas le domaine de
l'automobile avec un étrange village
planté sur le circuit du mans au n'y
entends parler anglais italiens français
mais surtout automobile et cinéma on
tourne un film sur les 24 heures du mans
le producteur l'acteur le voici steve
mcqueen
à 15 ans il était mécano prune compagnie
taxi sont cachés aujourd'hui 5 millions
de francs il a engagé 20 millions dans
le film le metteur en scène du film et
john sturgess à son actif west side
story les sept mercenaires pourtant
mcqueen veille à tous mcqueen devant la
caméra
mcqueen derrière quand c'est bon pour
tout le monde pour mac queen il faut
recommencer
les autres vedettes sont les voitures
avec elle non plus on ne triche pas
elles ont toutes couru au mans et pour
les besoins du film elles sont conduites
par leurs pilotes respectifs
hier après midi une partie du tournage a
été interrompu trois pilotes était
partie courir à hockenheim
entre chaque tour de piste sturgess et
mcqueen discutent du scénario il n'est
pas établi le temps la piste et les
voitures en dessiner mcqueen n'est pas
seulement producteur acteur il est aussi
fin pilote et ne cède jamais sa place
dans son baquet à quelques cascadeur
cette année il a terminé second à ces
bring l'une des compétitions les plus
importantes des etats unis
mais écoutons jugement de ses pairs
l'impression que steam mac il connaît
très bien là bas on connaît trop bien la
voiture il marche très bien
et on participe à l'est plus vraiment
lui va je crois même plus vite que
certains ici pas de problème notre
chasseur de primes jose randall a
abandonné le cheval pour la voiture mais
que préférera-t-il le cheveu c'est ton
meilleur ami jusqu'à ce qu'il te tue
quand la voiture c'est bien mais je
préfère la moto je suis un très mauvais
conducteurs et je pense que la course
c'est vraiment trop dangereux la moto
c'est vraiment ce qu'il ya de mieux
les sondés sourire et puis des 3 ponts
trois mois de tournage il devra quand
même le temps de chevaucher sa moto